bro Jared didn't oopsie James Charleston
probably the biggest observable time and
pity pie nope see this week I'm glory
pooping and you're watching penis what's
a PewDiePie dig do it locally this week
deer mate pretty pie here I just like to
apologize for my oopsie this week don't
know where to begin I thought the dog
from up was the dog from pants with the
dog from paint looks better than the
original Sonic I don't know how this
have happened and I just want to say how
deeply sorrow is sorrowful I am I know
I'm better than this let's get into why
everyone clicked on this video James
Charles biggest oopsie of 2019 James
Charles will have a scandal similar to
the one he's had before James Charles
absolutely not bum bum bum ba ba ba ba
ba pop up oopsy doopsy whoopsy poopsie
this is a big one James Charles who
going down to 16 million subscribers
and the internet could not be more
thrilled Congrats on 15 mil been here
since 60 James tars losing Jesus Lord
Almighty 1.4 million subscribers
breaking records in losing subscribers
faster than anyone has ever gained
subscribers so what happened well
youtuber totty totty totty made a video
called by sister a clever play on words
because James Charles slogan is hi
sisters and she called it bye sister
[Laughter]
now this video is 43 minutes long so I
did the favor of watching it for you
you are welcome Jesus Christ can you not
make it any more or less concise 43
minutes you expect everyone and people
know James Charles already he's pretty I
think most people in the beauty
community kind of the yes are really big
but in the beauty community but James
Charles is one of those figures that
kind of people know about him at least
and I think that's why this just got so
massive so what did she say well she
starts off by showing how they've been
friends for a long time and she's been
supporting James Charles for a long time
is here to do my Bridal makeup which is
what I am wearing right now I just
wanted to congratulate you on almost a
million on Instagram I want to say huge
congratulations to James Charles if you
have not checked his channel out on
YouTube all right we get it
she talks about why this video happened
in beginning like why she's calling out
James Charles buddy it's very confusing
unless you know what happened you're not
going to understand anything of a I'm
gonna share a lot of it with you because
I feel at this point that I have to
because Gabriel's more I decided a prett
what does that mean I don't understand
that God do I have to watch how many
videos have to watch I love him and I
therefore this kid so ruin through so
she's been supporting game for a long
time then she talks how Fame has changed
James Charles Fame power and a fat bank
account will change almost anyone and if
you don't have people that will tell you
to your face you're doing the wrong
things you will change and then she
finished off by completely
disassociating herself from James cross
it feels like she she feels responsible
for creating this monster that is James
Charles and it makes sense to
disassociate with that I don't want to
be friends with you I don't want to be
associated with you and I need to say
that very publicly so that this chapter
can just be closed she explains some
examples of how she helped James Charles
with contracts and her husband helping
him and all this sort of thing he didn't
have money for the flight or hotel so I
paid for that happily but your family
how can I help you
my husband would spend hours on the
phone looking over contracts getting him
in a better position so we helped him
get into a style Hall back when
basically no one wanted to work with him
because of his Ebola scandal and then
finally with the I think the most
hard-hitting thing is about how James
Charles kind of used his fame and power
to get straight people into getting with
him that's sort of his kink it seems but
okay right and she calls out what's
problematic about that literally made me
want to vomit oh my god you tried to
trick a straight man into thinking he's
gay yet again and somehow you're the
victim you know it's really disgusting
to manipulate someone's sexuality
especially when they are still you know
emerging into adulthood and don't quite
have everything figured out you are
using your fame your power your money to
play with people's emotions you're
threatening to ruin them you're
threatening to embarrass them that's
basically the gist of the video James
Cook Charles not a good person I think
there's plenty of reason to dislike him
I mean
seen so many strange things about him as
soon as anyone says anything about James
Charles you'll get this tweet saying
this is not funny delete this
immediately or my lawyer will be in
contact okay old disclaimer I'm not
excusing his behavior I don't think it's
right but we there's a massive amount of
backlash he's facing the biggest sub
drop that anyone's ever faced on YouTube
look at all the controversies that has
happened on YouTube is this really like
that comparable it seems to me like a
lot of people respect this taki figure
at least in the beauty community and
James Charles is already in this
controversial figure that people aren't
really sure about so for hit hard to
make this big sense of disassociating
herself from James Charles it seems that
a lot of people are just latching on to
that just to [ __ ] on James Charles which
I get it it's funny it's like everyone
is like because there are a couple
things about this that genuinely
bothered me when I saw it why did this
video actually being made why what cost
her to get so upset it's not really
clear in the video at least unless you
understand it what happen I looked into
it and the whole thing makes even less
sense at least you know for an outsider
I could still misunderstand things about
it but this is what caused the
controversy this Instagram post to a
sugar bear hair I met their team weekend
want a Coachella and they really helped
me my friends out with sister security
because it was crazy
you guys probably already know about
their iconic hair vitamins but they just
came out with brand new vegan sleep
vitamins and first of all it's Obama but
most importantly I've been dealing with
a lot of anxiety recently and it always
comes late at night when I'm laying in
bed thinking which is not fun or fresh
um so I've been taking these attorneys
on this before bed and they've been
really really hoping you guys want to
check it out you can sweep up James
Charles is dealing with existential
dread just take some sleep Vitamix okay
that's it that's what caused this whole
thing and that is what caused Tati to go
on Instagram and pose this big rant
about how obsessed she was when you do
so much for people in your life
and they not only don't return the favor
but they just don't even see you so why
was this a big deal for taffy well taffy
has her own brand of vitamins which our
health and beauty vitamins so for him to
not promote his friend her friends
vitamin product and still and promote
some other products
apparently she felt very betrayed by
this I'm just so upset the product that
James promoted was for sleeping pill
with brand new vegan asleep Patty's
product is for health and beauty yes the
company does do those type as well but
he specifically held up this bag of bold
bundle of sleep pills and that's what he
talked about their sleep so after Tati
made miss post on Instagram James
Charles deleted the post and apologized
said I want to publicly apologize to my
close friend Tati she's been like a
mother and blah blah blah support and
this weekend I didn't scream started for
vitamins cuz they helped me it would
secure it at Coachella I do not accept
any money party has a vitamin bribe
which I take daily I did not think about
the competition which was a major
oversight I've supported tightly both
online and up like she's done to me I'm
devastated that I heard someone that I
truly love and have endless respect for
so he deleted the poets didn't take any
money and a polytechnic maybe i'm naive
seems to me like this was an oversight
for my creators perspective i've done
this to a brand does you a favor and you
just be like alright fine and it's the
chain okay we're cool now it's kind of
like a throwaway thing it doesn't seem
impossible that this was just a mistake
you know it seems like the kind of thing
where they could just call each other
and resolve this but according to Tati i
want to share with you guys really
quickly why I'm being so public about
this because I know the first thing a
lot of people will say is hey why didn't
you pick up the phone
why didn't you message him back like you
guys should handle this privately
right why not I don't get it I really
don't get it let's hear the motivation
to why she decided to
this video to destroy game with Charles
courier I was planning on hopping in my
car and you know sitting down with him
but I changed my mind very very quickly
I was planning to talk to James but she
changed her mind why when I found out
that he had been giving his side to
Drama channels he had been in contact
with plenty of them I immediately knew
that this was all about damage control
and had little to do with his care for
me because I just don't so basically she
didn't resolve this privately with James
Charles because she found out that he's
been talking to drama channels something
that she admits that she's done as well
she said she talked to I have spoken to
drama channels that reached out and one
of them is here for the tea the other is
tea spill she's spoken to draw my
channels as well and this is the reason
why she didn't want to talk to James
well if you go to one of the drama
channels that she mentions t-cells they
post that James Charles said this until
toffee feels comfortable and ready to
talk to me in private I don't feel
comfortable commenting her about her
public immediately knew that this was
all about damage control and had little
to do with his care for me because I
just thought she was mad that he talked
to drama channels because she thought he
was gonna expose her this is what he
said I really don't get it I'm not here
to defend James Charles I just don't
think what's hot you did is that
justified she says how Fame changed
James Charles and that she's been his
mentor figure for her fame power and a
fat bank account will change almost
anyone she say she try to be that person
for him but I think it's worth noting
here that Tati is 37 years old James
Charles is still a teenager
yes he's 19 yes that is an excuse his
behavior but for a mother figure to just
completely drag this kid there's no one
no one has a problem with this over
something that could be resolved in
private I had P I have plenty of
youtubers
being unfair to me publicly that has
been humiliating but either we talk it
out in private or I just stop being
friends with them it's not that
difficult
I can't imagine just making a video
publicly dragging someone instead of
talking to them ignoring their calls and
just be like I'm gonna drag this person
online instead it feels very manipulated
this whole thing maybe you don't agree
with me on that but I have a few more
points to prove that and it's how she
talks about her brand if you ask people
what what did James Charles do people
will say oh he try to manipulate people
about their sexuality that was the big
drama right but then what has that to do
with Tatiana ex Brian's good enough on
its own and we're selling like hotcakes
like I don't need to at this point as we
grow maybe I will but that's not where
my spend is like I don't I'm not gonna
put $100,000 into an Instagram post for
someone to jam a pill in their mouth and
smiled it probably isn't taking it I'd
rather put that hundred thousand dollars
into research and creating a really dope
product that people really love and
that's why they come back for more
my product is selling like hotcakes I
just care about spending money to make
my product as good as possible
these are she's this is a mad go with my
intuition and to like really really try
to do the right thing and to be a good
person and I know I'm a role model and
that matters to me and that has gravity
to me people see me as a good person and
I know I'm a role model it feels a lot
like James Charles bad me very good very
good my brand good James Charles Baggett
and I want to make a difference and let
me also share that when I do reach the
level of success that I hope to with hey
I'm gonna make a lot of positive changes
they have huge plans for what I want to
do to give back and if you want to do
good with this brand
oh she has clients for huge changes to
do a lot of good then just do it saying
you're gonna do good things means
nothing okay it's this another thing it
just feels weird to me how everyone
absolutely
her look how many people like this video
it feels very manipulative she's putting
herself on a pedestal while she clearly
was completely find not outing this
behaviors about James Charles
essentially using people's sexuality and
as long as James Charles would have
instead promoted her vitamins she would
have been fine with it she would not
have made this video she would have been
good boy James Charles thank you very
much
all these issue the rights just because
it was an opportunity for her to do that
and I do have a big problem with that
and to be a good person and I know I'm a
role model and that matters to me
and the fact that a lot of people are
celebrating this ISM something positive
because yes it's fun to drag someone
online it's very troubling to me how
this sort of behavior gets rewarded
online this is 24 million views for me
to be the only one thinking this way it
feels bit weird to me that's why I feel
like I have to bring my opinion this
from a youtuber perspective James
Charles has not been secret about liking
straight guys it's something that he's
been spelling out for years
attractive straight boys will be some
people were fine with this until it
became a big deal until it's like oh
okay
now everyone instead of following James
Charles like all these people in the
community that are also so controversial
have all unfolded him I feel like there
has to be something else right actually
be something else that James Charles has
done that I don't know about that it
hasn't surfaced yet because otherwise
this is I just doesn't make sense to me
I'm not saying that I think is it isn't
I just say they both expose himself in
my opinion so again according to Tom P
this whole thing started because Todd do
you think that he went through this
elaborate stunt at Coachella about
security to make a promo for this
vitamin Brandon
gram and everyone's going T [ __ ]
cringe so pathetic all of you that was
my opinion I'm poppy po Pipo goodbye
[Music]